bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo company mic
alzheimer's bonjour michael nous voici
partis pour 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire marquée bien
sûr cette semaine par l'intervention
présidentielle à la télévision un choc
de simplification la taxe de 75% des
pistes sur les allocations familiales et
les retraites
françois hollande s'est surtout livré à
un exercice de pédagogie sur sa
politique et de la pédagogie il en a
besoin de chef de l'état était contesté
cette semaine jusque dans ses rangs il
faudrait que le chef de l'état a red se
comporter comme un président de conseil
général
voilà ce qu'a déclaré le début des
pascal cherki des propos qui font suite
aux critiques très vives du parti de
gauche le week-end précédent jean luc
mélenchon passé résolument dans une
opposition radicale
enfin sans transition aucune on va
parler à racolage passif et dans cette
émission une sénatrice a demandé et
obtenu la fin du délit en la matière
instaurée en 2003 et jugé inefficace
la proposition de loi là encore devra
passer le cap de l'assemblée est avec
nous pour commenter toute cette
actualité marie george buffet
bonjourbonjour député communiste alors
il ya une tradition dans cette émission
eh bien on laisse aux parlementaires le
soin de dresser votre portrait je vous
propose de les écouter
marie george buffet je ne partage pas
ses combats politiques
elle dit souvent des choses fortes est
fausse c'est une femme de caractère de
conviction et j'apprécie
particulièrement l'action qu'elle a
menées en tant que ministre des sports
en particulier contre le dopage
on sent quelqu'un qui pense qu'elle dit
et on peut ne pas être d'accord mais je
vous dis il ya tellement de langue de
bois de cynisme dans cet hémicycle qu'un
peu de fraîcheur et de sincérité se fait
pas de mal je les pratiquer en tout cas
lors du débat sur le mariage pour tous
je les trouvais extrêmement pertinente
on était très unie je vais on était
vraiment sur les mêmes idées sur le sur
la même tonalité
marie george buffet une femme de
conviction ça on n'en doute absolument
pas une femme qui dit les vérités c'est
plutôt rare en politique pas qu'on soit
une femme et dire la vérité en politique
c'est plutôt rare chaque fois que je
parle en politique comme vous dites j'ai
toujours dans la tête des gens que j'ai
rencontrés quelques heures ou quelques
jours avant des gens qui justement eux
n'ont pas le droit à la parole donc
j'essaye à chaque fois de traduire leurs
envies ou leur colère ou et je
m'aperçois souvent que notre discours à
nous les hommes et les femmes politiques
nous employons toute une série de mode
de deux formules et qui ne sont pas les
mots et les formules qui sont employés
qui ont apparaissent trop souvent comme
des gens qui sont un peu hors champ
voilà et je pense que la politique doit
regagner en proximité ça ne veut pas
dire devenir simpliste bien au contraire
essayer de transposer la parole des
français
dans les missives j'essaye à chaque fois
dû forcer de déplaire à vos collègues
députés
mais je vois mon signifie monsieur
mariton s'est opposé pendant toute une
plus d'une semaine prennent des jours
sur le mariage pour tous et toutes
il a ses convictions j'ai les miennes
mais on peut aussi se respecter à partir
du moment où il ya de la sincérité
ceux qui le connaissent bien des aussi
sacré caractère l'argent chez oui je
m'écarte rg non je suis quelqu'un de
très angoissé et donc
oui je suis pas quelqu'un sur qui si sûr
sûr de moi donc ça me donne ce parfois
de la nervosité donc je peux en effet
des moments un peu de colère
l'apparition de soi avoir quand même des
convictions avoir des convictions cela
ne veut pas dire ne pas douter
moi je doute souvent de de jeu remet en
cause certaines de mes idées c'est mieux
je crois mais on va dérouler ensemble
fil de la semaine on va consacrer le
début de cette émission à l'intervention
télévisée de françois hollande ce jeudi
soir c'est quand ce grand oral 1h15
d'intervention a donc pour le chef de
l'état avec une grande partie bien sûr
consacré aux questions économiques et
budgétaires françois hollande confirme
qu'il entend bien inverser la courbe du
chômage d'ici la fin de l'année
il présente la palette de ses outils et
fait une annonce la taxe à 75%
ce sera finalement une taxe versée par
les entreprises sur leurs très hauts
salaires on écoute françois hollande
j'avais souhaité qu'on introduise cette
contribution de 75 % conseil
constitutionnel a pris une décision je
la respecte et donc je vais procéder
différemment dans les entreprises
d'abord il doit y avoir une transparence
des rémunérations dans les plus grandes
entreprises parce que ça ne se passe que
dans les plus grandes entreprises ces
rémunérations au dessus d'un million
d'euros dans les grandes entreprises
transparence l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires sera consultée sur ses
rémunérations et lorsque la rémunération
dépasse 1 million d'euros est bien
l'entreprise aura une contribution à
payer qui la met toute sa position
confondues atteindra 75 % marie george
buffet c'était vraiment une des
promesses phares du candidat hollande
une mesure qui fait pschitt tout ça pour
ça fonctionne espèces d'une usine à gaz
complètement incompréhensible ce qu'il
faut si réellement mettre devant le
parlement un projet de loi pourtant sur
une réforme de la fiscalité dans notre
pays voilà ce qu'il faut faire a été
fait
ce n'est pas que je fais financer 75 %
c'est pas une vraie avait formulé la
fiscalité c'est une mesurette 75% mais
je vous dis que par rapport à l' usine à
gaz que j'ai proposé qu'on sonne il faut
une réforme de la fiscalité notamment
pour l'impôt sur le revenu il faut qu'il
soit réellement progressif et donc nous
propose aux quatorze tranches front de
gauche 2 pour graduer la peau sans
revenu et puis il faut une fiscalité
intelligente pour les entreprises
l'entreprise qui consacre des moyens à
la recherche à l'innovation à la
qualification aux salaires il faut lui
faire du bonus au niveau de sa fiscalité
l'entreprise qui ne pensent qu'au coût
du capital aux dividendes etc
il plonge de reprise lent même pour le
pétrole ça ne sert à rien cela ça leur
rapporte et répétez le sait rien sur ces
très hauts salaires jarre depardieu a eu
tort de partir finalement une res que
rien là ce sont que les très hauts
salaires
oui tous et où tous les autres personnes
extrêmement fortunée que ce pays ne
risque rien ou ne touche on n'impose pas
ou ne pose pas réellement les revenus
financiers le capital soyons clairs
voilà donc c'est une c'est une mesurette
c'est pour ça je vous dis il faut une
grande réforme de la fiscalité la
campagne présidentielle de françois
hollande
un symbole qui restent donc les
propositions de campagne finalement ils
les maintiens prix en fait qu'il reste
dans une usine à gaz
c'est pas les 75 % c'est encore autre
chose qui est inventé etc
c'est pas si ça dira le jour à jour
d'ailleurs françois hollande s'en prend
aussi aux plus aisés alors évidemment
dans une catégorie 1 sous les
allocations familiales
les catégories les ménages les plus
aisés toucherait moins face à vous
semble une bonne à jour il faut rappeler
l'origine des allocations familiales
les allocations familiales c'est une
allocation universelle qui disent
l'enfant c'est à dire qu'elle est versée
pour que l'enfant puisse vivre dans de
bonnes conditions
voilà donc c'est à l'enfant de sa part
thierry d'allocations familiales alors
on touche des allocations familiales
pour faire entrer de l'argent c'est tout
voilà et on ne touche pas pour faire
plus d'égalité parce que si on prend un
peu d'allocations familiales aux plus
aisés alors faut donner plus
d'allocations familiales à ceux qui
souffrent le plus il a c'est parce qu'on
nous proposons nous propose de prendre
aux allocations familiales des plus
aisées pour remettre dans les caisses
point final et dernier élément déjà
c'est une bonne chose de faire
participer les plus aisés à cet effort
pour faire participer pour participer
les plus la pocket plus d'argent dans
les caisses de la protection sociale
il faut faire cotiser les revenus
financiers il a on résoudra les
problèmes à la fois des allocations
familiales mais aussi des retraites et
des autres prestations
mais je voudrais aussi en faire une
remarque sur la proposition de monsieur
le prénom la république à partir de quel
niveau vous êtes une famille aisée
il avait évoqué la somme de 4000 euros
si vous vous aussi je me trompe pas il
souhaitait 4000 euros je ne sais pas
pour vous mais moi je ne suis pas dans
les chiffres comme ça des seuils ghetto
4000 euros si on applique une
suppression ou une diminution forte des
allocations familiales d'un ménage qu'il
aime 4000 euros j'ai peur j'ai peur que
ça conduisent la femme bien sûr pas
l'homme la femme à arrêter de travailler
et ça il faut faire attention à ça parce
que nous sommes un pays et je m'en
félicite qui a fort taux de natalité
encore les statistiques viennent de
montrer nous sommes un peu les champions
les champions d'europe
parce que tout en étant des femmes qui
continuent à travailler y compris
lorsqu'elles ont trois enfants nous
avons le taux de travail des femmes
mères de trois enfants 10 le plus élevé
pourquoi parce que nous avons les
allocations familiales parce que nous
avons les crèches collectif parce que
nous avons la maternelle à trois ans
donc ne remettons pas cela opposent
parce que le travail pour la femme c'est
l'indépendance à présent des retraites
le président de la république l'a aussi
a fait une annonce on va l'écouter tout
de suite pour ceux qui auront cotisé
longtemps ils doivent pouvoir partir à
temps mais comme on vit plus longtemps
l'espérance de vie s'allonge
très bien il va falloir avoir des durées
de cotisation plus longue ça ça sera
l'objet de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux mais sur le principe
de la désindexation c'est à dire la
diminution des pensions pas pour les
petites retraites c'est impossible d'en
parler ça n'est pas exclue pas pour les
retraites de base
donc ça sera fait c'est impossible que
nous soyons dans une remise en cause de
ce qui est le droit fondamental pour les
retraités d'avoir le maintien de leurs
pensions donc il y aura une discussion
sur les paramètres tous les paramètres
cotisations indexation et allongement de
la durée de cotisation que l'un des
mouvements de la durée de cotisation
c'est mieux c'est plus efficace que le
relèvement de l'âge minimum du départ à
la retraite
peut-être quelle autre solution
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres solutions
que celles qui sont proposées par le
président de la république je viens de
l'évoquer tout à l'heure nous sommes
battus tout au long du débat sur les
retraites sous l'ère sarkozy nous sommes
battus les députés communistes pour
porter l'idée d'une cotisation des
revenus financiers au même taux que
celle des salariés pour le avoir les
moyens pour assurer les retraites pour
chacun et chacune il faut aussi se
battre pour l'emploi qualifié et bien
rénumérés et donc d'écouter utilisation
qui correspondent à 6 emplois qualifiés
bien rénumérés ces 5 milliards de
déficit a pour le moment je rêve mais
justement c'est pas mais justement à
chaque fois d'autres choix aux contrats
maintenant la preuve est faite à chaque
fois que des gouvernements décident
d'allonger ce qui a été fait sous l'ère
sarkozy ou d'augmenter les cotisations
3,81 qu on nous répond ça va pas parce
que justement ne s'attaque pas là alors
à la cause du mal d'être d'accord
françois hollande d'heure me we need
éclosion l'idée que le temps de vie
s'allonge et donc il faut
automatiquement travailler plus
longtemps est une idée je trouve qui est
contraire aux annonces et de
civilisation bravo si le temps de vie se
poursuivent bravo si les gens peuvent
bénéficier date en plus l'eau en bonne
santé à la retraite entend bien là vous
n'êtes vraiment pas satisfaite de ces de
ces mesures de françois hollande et de
cette politique vous vous félicitez de
ne pas être entré au gouvernement
oui parce que vraiment depuis
depuis dix mois nous n'avons aucun signe
d'une volonté de mener une véritable
politique de bush ce gouvernement a
adopté le traité sarkozy m me merkel qui
impose l'austérité aux pays de l'union
européenne et on voit bien les résultats
de cette austérité dans ces pays que ce
soit la grèce l'italie l'espagne ou la
france
ce gouvernement au lieu de faire appel à
la mobilisation citoyenne à la
mobilisation sociale pour obtenir de
nouvelles avancées sociales et
économiques
au contraire a suivi le medef sur un
accord de flexibilité et là nous annonce
une nouvelle période de réduction des
dépenses publiques et de ridder et des
mesures antisociales
donc on ne peut pas suivre ce
gouvernement c'est une question très
simple si c'était à refaire vous
voteriez à nouveau françois hollande oui
parce qu'il fallait enfin écoutez je
suis de bouche et à aucun moment je
devrai laisser repasser
nicolas sarkozy donc oui bien sûr au
second tour j'ai appelé immédiatement à
voter pour françois hollande et je les
fais et je le referais bien évidemment
mais ceci dit j'ai le droit de dire que
je suis insatisfait justement parce que
je suis de gauche je lui fais on va pas
du tout petit peu de l'accord sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi qui est est en
commission des affaires sociales cette
semaine à l'assemblée et qui arrive dans
l'hémicycle mardi prochain dont plus de
flexibilité de l'emploi
est ce que votre groupe votera pour
contre notre groupe ne votera pas l'ani
qui nous veut du mal moi aussi l'accord
donc signé par certains syndicats pas
parler c'est à dire vous voterez contre
vous abstiendra cuts et où nous allons
donner une bataille parlementaire nous
avons nous allons déposer de très
nombreux amendements du oui mais ce sont
des amendements qui visent à remplacer
arctique partie des mesures de
flexibilité des mesures d'insécurité
pour les salariés par des propositions
très constructive pour garantir une
sécurité d'emploi et de formation pour
donner de nouveaux droits syndicaux une
nouvelle représentation syndicale
françois hollande m'a george buffet il
ne changera pas la loi si les
partenaires sociaux ne sont pas d'accord
va soumettre le parlement oui
apparemment bien donne toute décision
toute exclusive relatiosn mans sera
sourire tout c'est peut-être une phrase
qui fait sourire mais je suis élu du
peuple
ai je le droit de défendre mes opinions
semblait nationale et dont on me fera
pas taire un ne fera pas taire le groupe
du front de gauche
il défendra ses amendements ils ne
voteront pas une loi qui correspond au
souhait du medef ça nous l'avons trop
bas mais pour les autres syndicats ça
veut dire aussi par exemple qu'il va
falloir négocier avec les syndicats
une fois que cette loi sera votée ils
peuvent décider de ne pas appliquer oui
ma faim si jamais tu s'échangeait à la
virgule près ce que j'appelle j'appelle
les salariés vraiment à se renseigner
sur le contenu de cet accord
j'ai été signé par trois syndicats snu
syndicat pas son nom il représente non
non c'est pas la majorité syndicale si
on ne peut pas compter comme ça ils
représentent les trois syndicats
consignes et représente 39 % d'audience
syndicale les deux qui ont refusé
représente 50 % d'audience à l'ica donc
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
alors il ya eu cette semaine la sortie
d'un député socialiste qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue pascal cherki député de
paris qui déplore l'excès d'austérité de
la politique hollande il vous rejoins et
il le dit à sa façon à lui si on écoute
on doit se hausser au niveau et arrêter
de jouer petit bras
arrêtez de ses discours que personne
n'entend que personne ne comprend le
redressement dont la justice se nommant
modèle français
l'espèce de novlangue imbitable
maintenant il faut fixer des objectifs
clairs
quand on est président de la france on
n'est pas conseiller général d'un canton
parce que j'ai trouvé que françois
hollande jeudi soir et parlé comme un
conseiller général du canton
d'abord on s'est tous un peu ce prouvy
irrévérencieux pour les conseillers
généraux qui jouent leur rôle au niveau
du département
cette partie de la phrase bon mais je
comprends que certains députés
socialistes soient un peu dans le même
état d'esprit - c'est-à-dire comptait
cette politique qui nous mène droit dans
le mur et ont vite que l'on revienne
vraiment aux grandes réformes de bouche
dont on a besoin vraiment que
l'électorat de gauche décroche de
françois l'europe c'est la
sociale-démocrate un critique il faut
concerter il faut pas sans moyens
j'étais dans une nonne sommes dans un
quartier de demas ville aux tilleuls où
nous étions débat justement sur l'accord
de fait si billy t on expliquer aux
personnes présentes dans cet accord et
j'entendais un monsieur du travail dans
le bâtiment qui m'expliquait que dans
son entreprise il ya eu cette expression
les salariés ont peur
alors il s'est expliqué ils ont peur
parce que il ya plus de travail
ils ont peur des cli censier un autre
nous expliquer sa déception il est je
suis de gauche mais aussi je sais plus
si c'est une politique de droite ou de
gauche qui monnaie
il faut se rendre compte que la
souffrance sociale aujourd'hui françois
hollande ne devrait pas dire parce que
c'est ce qu'on a beaucoup entendu la
part des députés socialistes cette
semaine devrait pas dire je suis un
social démocrate et j'assume cette
social-démocratie pour qu'au moins on se
sache très exactement ça changera quoi
là ça changera pas la politique qu'il
mène et ça changera pas la vie des gens
dont faillite on s'en moque un peu
parce que vous savez il ya des mesures
qui auraient pu prendre par exemple de
prendre un exemple parce que nous sommes
fin mars les expulsions reprennent les
discussions leucate yves avec des gens
qui sont au chômage ou en maladie depuis
longtemps qu'ils n'arrivent plus à payer
qu'on va expulser on n'aurait pas pu
décider un gouvernement de gauche
n'aurait pas pu décider d'interdire les
expulsions locatives pour les locataires
de bonne foi il n'aurait pas pu le
décider là on va encore mettre des
familles à la rue et nous sommes sous un
gouvernement de gauche
mais moi j'attends de la gauche
d'ailleurs je poserai cette question une
fois que j'aurai une question
d'actualité jeu j'attends du
gouvernement qu'il décide pour profiter
plus aux expulsions locatives
marie george buffet lui encore une
critique contre françois hollande
en tout cas tout en nuance et avec
humour elle gêne belgique c'est celle de
nicolas sarkozy l'ancien président de la
république qui est ressorti du bois pour
s'exprimer
vous allez voir tout en nuances écouter
tu alléger la taxation des heures
supplémentaires tu a supprimé des taux
d'imposition jugé comme confiscatoire 52
ou 55%
je précise que je ne parle que de la
belgique
un cousin parmi les belges
voilà c'était à l'occasion d'une remise
de décoration un ancien ministre belge
mais là on voit bien tout simplement que
c'est une vraie critique contre la
politique fiscale et mentor de france en
blanc est ce que madame buffet au delà
tout ça est ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on imagine que le match
hollande sarkozy c'est reparti pour 2010
est d'abord 2017 si loin c'est pour
pouvoir arrêter de vivre que pour la
présidentielle dans ce pays parce que il
ya des tas de choses à faire d'ici 2017
bon nicolas sarkozy va pas nous donner
des leçons parce que le son bilan il est
là un son bilan son bilan c'est une
politique osterrieth r1 avec toute une
série de lois qui ont privé de droits
des hommes et des femmes qui vivent sur
notre territoire et qui ont fait
beaucoup de mal au plan social donc
nicolas sarkozy on n'en veut pas qu'il
reste en belgique est bon mais ceci dit
moi ce qui me fait le plus mal au mal au
coeur ce qui me fait plus mal au coeur
c'est qui peut se permettre de rigoler
comme les rigoles là on parle en parce
que il voit bien qu'en france le
changement on n'arrive pas et donc ça
donne des ailes à la droite qui te ou
voix la droite à l'assemblée jour après
jour qui nous donne des leçons en disant
qu'ils donnent des leçons gouvernement
disant mais vous croyez divisé pas
encore assez les dépenses publiques
allez encore un effort
le gouvernement réduisait encore un peu
plus ses dépenses publiques voilà et ça
moi j'ai envie de redonner un peu
d'honneur à la gauche un peu de sens à
une politique de gauche pour que la
droite n'est plus justement sourire aux
lèvres eh bien on va reprendre ensemble
fil de la semaine va commencer avec le
lundi c'est normal tiens tiens encore
des critiques sur le gouvernement
en ce lundi l'actualité bruite encore
des attaques lancées pendant le week end
par le parti de gauche de jean luc
mélenchon vous êtes sûrement suivi avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les noms d'oiseaux
ont fusé lors du congrès du parti à
bordeaux principale cible le ministre de
l'économie pierre moscovici premier prix
pour son action à chypre c'est un sujet
de pierre l'asca et betty lachguer le
congrès du parti de gauche avait
pourtant bien commencé hommage à la
révolution portugaise ou encore adoption
d'un texte sur l'éco socialisme et puis
au détour d'un débat sur la gestion de
la crise chypriote françois delapierre
un des fidèles lieutenants de jean luc
mélenchon s'en prend directement au
ministre de l'économie dit pierre
moscovici a voté et a défendu le fait qu
on spolie les déposants chypriote pour
renflouer les banques
ça c'est un acte de salopards et je les
dis avec force et nous continuerons à le
dire avec force j'ai mis en cause
moscovici communiste de la france et les
décisions qu'il a prises ou parce que
nous mettons en cause la finance
internationale
le ton est dur volontairement provoquant
quelques heures plus tard à la tribune
jean luc mélenchon défense nos camarades
et attise les braises
les membres du parti de gauche parle cru
et dru ne tourne pas deux heures autour
du pot utilise les mots qui claquent
parce que je nomme un chat un chat et
qu'un de mes camarades appellent un
un
côté socialiste c'est pierre moscovici
lui même qui se charge de rappeler à
jean luc mélenchon
les bornes à ne pas dépasser c'est pas
un dérapage au sens où sa logorrhée
fourchette quelqu'un de très intelligent
jean luc mélenchon il sait ce qu'il dit
il le fait exprès et je dis que là
monsieur mélenchon attention il est en
train par détestation la
social-démocratie par détestation du
parti socialiste de franchir certaines
board
le parti de gauche semble donc haussé le
ton face au parti socialiste
au risque de tomber parfois dans
l'insulté public et de couper
définitivement tout lien avec le ps au
risque aussi de couper tout lien avec
les communistes les communistes et nos
amis du parti de gauche nous sommes très
attachés au front de gauche que nous
avons réalisé quelque chose de beau
puisque nous avons réussi à rassembler
plusieurs fronts nous avons réalisé
quelque chose de beau parent ce qui crée
une alternative à gauche c'est une crème
dynamique jean luc mélenchon est un
homme comme l'a dit pierre moscovici
d'une très grande intelligence
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a su pendant
la campagne des présidentielles redonner
du sens une politique de bush tu rentres
le péché les communistes ça je peux vous
assurer que nous sommes en ce moment
même en campagne contre l'austérité
ensemble pierre laurent et jean-luc
mélenchon pour faire plusieurs meetings
en commun dans plusieurs villes de
france dont il n'y a pas de problème de
au sein du fonds de l'eau à positionner
arrêt au départ là comment vous
positionner par rapport à cette phrase
cette année la ligue est une femme veut
respectueuse de moi c'est pas ma façon
je les lis je lui dis chiche que j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de leurs biens c'est
pas ma façon d'être né mieux parler je
pense que on n'a pas besoin d'ajouter
des noms des noms d'oiseaux dans le
débat politique pour soi ferme sur la
dénonciation de choix politiques ou même
pour soi ferme sur la dénonciation d'un
comportement d'un homme d'une femme
politique ça n'y a pas de jets pas de
souci par rapport à cela mais je pense
que les noms d'oiseaux c'est pas utile
beaujolais déjà dit je leur dirai quand
je verrai françois delapierre je dirais
beau je trouve que c'est un peu dommage
parce que moi j'ai écouté l'ensemble du
discours de jean luc mélenchon il a dit
des choses très importantes
notamment sur sa vision des pays qui
entourent la méditerranée et enfin une
bombe du congrès du parti de gauche on
ne garde que la phrase si l'enfant est
atteint quand elle est aussi forte que
celle de réchauffement c'est pas très
bon il est intelligent que ça a un peu
gâché leur congrès puis si on n'a pas vu
tout ce qu'ils ont dit d'autres et
d'intérêts sont alors je vous en ai des
négociations avec le parti socialiste si
des négociations il hier au vue des
municipales parce qu'il est aujourd'hui
hors de question pour les municipales
nous devons construire des programmes
municipaux avec les populations
il faut lancer des ateliers citoyens où
on va discuter des programmes des bilans
etc et le front de gauche pour moi je le
dis il doit avoir comme vocation pour
une municipale de rassembler le plus
largement possible la gauche pour faire
en sorte que toutes les mairies de
gauche reste à gauche et toutes les
mairies on peut gagner à gauche soit
gagner à gauche pour que répondent aux
besoins et pas ça veut dire qu'il faut
travailler avec l'ensemble des forces de
gauche je suit les rennais s'est enfin
écouter lahoud moi je suis dans une
ville où nous travaillons depuis cinq
ans de quatre ans maintenant ensemble
nous allons tirer le bilan nous allons
lancer des ateliers citoyens et nous
allons appeler toute la gauche à se
rassembler pour poursuivre ensemble
mélenchon annonçait déjà qu'il voulait
pour les municipales de 2014 des listes
autonomes dans une soixantaine de villes
vous le suivez ou vous le suivez pas
mais pourquoi a priori dire qu'il faut
des listes autonomes
nous sommes dans un délire nous sommes
dans un front de gauche donc je peux
avoir des différences avec jean luc
mélenchon
voilà il donnera aux finalement et on va
voir et tout commence le débat citoyen
avec bo xi dans des villes il n'est pas
possible de rassembler la gauche
il vient il faut y aller il faut y aller
en liste front de gauche il ya des vies
ou parti socialiste peut-être que
vouloir partir seul dayan bon je vois
vers chez moi des tentations de leur
part dans les villes que avec des maires
communistes bon mais essayons moi c'est
mon obsession pour l'instant essayons de
rassembler entre vous mais oui il va se
parler avec eux
si on retire la vie facile à jean luc
mélenchon en deux mots oui non oui oui
tout est franchement ça n'a pas été
facile ni pour moi ni pour lui lorsqu'on
a décidé d'aller vers le front de gauche
avec nos camarades parce que moi il
fallait que je sois en confiance avec
jean luc mélenchon qu'il allait ou non
quitter le parti socialiste
et lui il fallait qu'il soit en
confiance envers moi que j'allais aller
vers la création de ce front et donc
nous allons créer des liens de confiance
et moi je souhaite que s'il ya une
confiance perdure on va passer au mardi
si vous le voulez bien georges puchon a
parlé de cette loi sur le mariage pour
tous et après la forte mobilisation du
week end dernier ils sont nombreux à
attendre l'examen au sénat qui va
débuter le 4 avril le vote s'annonce
serrée chaque voix va compter
et bien la ministre de la justice
christiane taubira est venu sonner la
mobilisation devant les élus socialistes
on écoute tous les détails avec marie
brémaud les milliers de manifestants
contre le mariage pour tous attendaient
une réponse de la part du gouvernement
suite à leur démonstration de force dans
la rue au sénat ce matin la garde des
sceaux est sorti de son silence
j'ai très très attentive à toute
expression et notamment à l'expression
démocratique
je serai très attentif l'expression
démocratique elle se elle se trouve
également dans nos institutions
senna d'interroger les sénateurs à
écouter le rapporteur du texte au sénat
la position de la majorité sur le
mariage pour tous ne bougera pas moi je
n'ai jamais été
impressionné par les manifestations
quelle qu'elle soit et quelques nombre
qu'elle comporte
ce n'est pas la rue qui fait la loi le
parlement fait la loi au sénat sur ce
texte polémique la majorité reste
étroite
mais la gauche devrait pouvoir compter
sur quelques voix à droite et au centre
et à ceux qui reprochent au gouvernement
de délaisser le social au profit des
sujets de société
la ministre déléguée à la famille
n'hésite pas à faire référence aux
figures historiques et politiques du
passé
il ne s'agit pas d'opposer les lois
sociales et eloi sociétale imaginez que
de gaulle en 1944 lorsque il prend les
rênes de la france libérée dix et le
temps est à la reconstruction le droit
de vote des femmes on verra plus tard
maintenant il a pas raisonner de la
sorte il a donné à la fois il a
reconstruit la france
il a donné le droit de vote aux femmes
car visiblement les socialistes veulent
faire du mariage pour tous un texte qui
marquera la cinquième république
au même titre que la loi contre la peine
de mort ou l'avortement mais ceux qui
s'y opposent n'ont pas dit leur dernier
mot marie george buffet lors du débat à
l'assemblée nationale vous aviez déposé
un amendement sur la procréation
médicalement assistée
françois hollande à la télévision il a
dit je suivrai l'avis du comité
consultatif national d'éthique sur la
pma même si la vie est contraire oui
mais je leur ai dit c'est la victoire
des anti mariage pour tout ça si on peut
dire mais c'est vrai qu'on aurait dû
aborder ces questions de la pma dès la
première lecture de la loi sur le
mariage pour tous et tout parce que on
nous a répondu lorsque j'ai déposé mon
amendement ainsi que les verts
d'ailleurs qui avait déposé un
amendement similaire
on nous a répondu on verra après pour la
pme on verra après la pma s'est autorisé
en france
la procréation médicalement assistée est
autorisé en france que un couple
homosexuel de fans
oui mais elle est encadrée mais
l'encadrement résoudrait pour couples de
femmes s'étaient faut avoir un projet
d'un projet de vie pour l'enfant faut
avoir bien sûr c'est normal donc une
femme aujourd'hui peut avoir accès à la
pma donc que ce droit soit ouvert pour
un couple homosexuel de femmes ça me
paraît tout à fait normal
contrairement à la jpa la jpa la
gestation pour autrui dit familièrement
mère porteuse
est interdite enfin là il s'est de tout
et c'est non et moi je partage ce point
de vue il faut interdire la gpa parce
que c'est l'instrumentalisation du corps
est souvent la marchandisation très
clair oui on agit on imagine que l'avis
consultatif
s'il est négatif mais je le ferai parce
que oui je le regrette parce que
beaucoup de femmes attendent justement
de pouvoir avoir des enfants grâce à la
paix m
un peu trompé là sur ce texte parce que
on vous avait dit bon pas de pma dans ce
texte la voter le mariage pour que le
mariage pour tous et puis on verra ça
plus tard vous aurez ça dans une loi sur
la famille à partir du moment où le
groupe socialiste a retiré son
amendement sur la pma j'ai compris que
ce serait un combat difficile
on a un peu menti aux députés
socialistes qui ont accepté de retirer
oui je pense que enfin moi j'étais son
illusion elle va passer au mercredi
encore de la grogne
oui désolé cette fois ce sont les
sénateurs socialistes qui s'y met
est ce une révolte pas une révolution ce
mercredi la quasi totalité des sénateurs
socialistes mais aussi les communistes
vont s'allier à droite pour adopter au
sénat une proposition de loi sur les
allocations familiales
en résumé celles ci ne seront plus que
très partiellement versés pour les
familles à qui on a retiré la garde des
enfants par décision de justice
pourquoi pas pourrait-on dire sauf que
ce texte n'était pas du tout soutenu par
le gouvernement l'acte législatif
devient alors acte de rébellion
delphine gérard sa couleur politique
le socialiste yves daudigny il a laissé
au placard à la tribune il s'est fait
l'avocat du texte abandonnant sa
ministre or dominique bertinotti opposés
au projet il faut dire que cette loi il
l'avait lui-même présent c'est à
quelques mots près quelques mois plus
tôt elle n'avait pas l'appui
du gouvernement donc elle n'a pas été
présentée dans une niche
la majorité sénatoriale et savez vous
pourquoi on a repris la proposition
d'olli tambédou parce que elle même
avait repris la proposition pêchue de
juillet 2012 belge est une roche et
c'est pour ça que nous pouvons être
fiers de voter aujourd'hui la
proposition béchu amende et de dix
objectif de ce texte transférées au
département une partie des allocations
familiales versées aux parents des
enfants placés sur décision de justice
elle représente une forme de consensus
de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
considèrent que on doit moraliser ce
dispositif d'allocation familiales pour
les enfants placés et que c'est pas une
question de droite ou de gauche c'est
une question d'équité et de morale un
consensus droite-gauche inhabituelle au
sénat et surtout un violent camouflet
pour le gouvernement
le gouvernement aurait dû se rallier ou
pensions à cette proposition de loin à
partir du moment où comme je le disais
tout à l'heure où l'allocation familiale
visent le bien-être de l'enfant il est
normal qu'une partie de cette allocation
appartement mon enfant est placé aille
au département qui justement lui va
financer la famille d'accueil de cet
enfant donc c'est pas choquant que cette
loi soit après l'aspect moral faisons
attention je vois pas très bien ce que
vient faire la morale dans cette affaire
c'est une question de logique rapport à
l'objectif des allocations familiales
vous voterez cette proposition de loi
quant à lui à l'assemblée c'est leur
fraudeur notamment quand on dort aussi
sur dans un autre sens par exemple
contre le cumul des mandats mais ça
c'est pas bien là et pas le gouvernement
le sénat aussi c'est un petit peu là que
ça se passe finalement la critiquer et
la fin mai le sénat est dans une
situation où il ya une majorité de
gauche qui est très très fragile donc
bien évidemment les les débats sont sont
plus souples utah s'est rebellé vote
serré donc groupe communiste finalement
que les communistes en plus de pouvoir
en ce moment c'est au sénat va à nouveau
et la triste non
du tout je suis attaché à ma
circonscription j'ai pas de problème non
non mais je trouve que ça permet en
effet au groupe communiste et du front
de gauche de pouvoir poser plus sur le
contenu des lois et c'est bien on voit
temps assez souvent finalement avec
l'ump
mais si on ne vote pas avec l'ump mon
vote contre des lois qui nous
apparaissent contraires aux intérêts de
coller avec multi sites avec l'ump avec
l'ump mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
c'est pas de notre faute à berne oublie
pas que vous avez été ministre des
sports c'était dans le gouvernement de
lionel jospin
vous avez été auditionnés au sénat dans
une commission denquête la semaine
dernière eh bien on va en parler puisque
c'était sur l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage
vous avez annoncé dépression ou va bien
sûr et revenir cette semaine la
commission va redditionnelle à nouveau
des experts est aussi un ancien ministre
des sports jean-françois lamour
le tout suivi par joachim robe comment
améliorer la lutte contre le dopage
question d'autant plus importante
qu'aujourd'hui tous les sports sont
touchés et les mauvais élèves ne sont
pas forcément ceux auxquels on pense le
sport qui nous donne plus aux forts
pourcentages de positif est le rugby
vient ensuite le football en troisième
position se trouve l'athlétisme en
quatrième
le triathlon en cinquième le basketball
en sixième le cyclisme mais pas facile
de faire bouger les lignes
la semaine dernière marie george buffet
avait parlé des pressions subies à cause
d'un contrôle de l'équipe de france de
football avant la coupe du monde 98
chantal jouanno reconnaît que toutes les
fédérations sportives ne collabore pas à
la lutte contre le dopage
j'ai pas subi de pression clairement il
y avait une volonté
ne me demandez pas en parler ça oui de
ne pas en parler de ne pas dire qu il y
avait des problèmes de dopage une pas
dire qu dans le sport aucun sport
n'était à l'abri du dopage autre
problème le dopage de plus en plus
fréquente chez les amateurs et sans le
suivi sans le contrôle médical dont
profitent les tricheurs professionnels
un autre problème auquel la commission
denquête aimerait s'attaquer
elle doit rendre son rapport avant la
fin du mois george buffet lorsque vous
avez été auditionné vous aviez parlé de
pressions
à l'époque quand il avait dit diligenter
des enquêtes de sur le dopage à propos
de l'équipe de france de football 98
championne du monde il faut le rappeler
quelles étaient ces conditions c'était
dans le cadre de la préparation de
l'équipe de france avant les coupes du
monde et c'était pendant un stage à
tignes j'en avais des anges diligenter
un contrôle inopiné et je veux me
rappelle que tous les médias m'était
tombé dessus avec une le jeu en fait je
perturbais l'équipe de france j'allais
faire on sent que la pression des médias
simplement mieux mais je pense que les
toutous lippini oui les médias reflétait
je pense l'opinion c'est à dire aux
déranger l'équipe qui allait peut-être
gagné la coupe du monde on n'a pas eu
lieu si si l'alluré la presse ça s'est
déclenchée bon partout c'était on essaie
tout au début de la lutte contre le
dopage en somme en 98 et a été très
difficile au début
rappelez vous que lorsque nous avons eu
la candidature pour paris 2008
j'ai eu de pression énorme de pour
essayer de faire abandonner la loi de
page française parce qu'elle était au
top niveau par rapport à d'autres
législations mais donc c'est une
pression médiatique populaire il ya
d'autres pressions oui vous avez des
pressions de la part de membres du cio
on m'a demandé de ma exigé que je rédige
une lettre assurant que j'allais mettre
de côté la loi antidopage pour les shows
pour les jeux olympiques jeu le premier
ministre m'a soutenu
au niveau politique vous avez été
soutenu de tous les bords je n'ai jamais
eu de pression d'hommes ou de femmes
politiques jamais j'ai pas souvenir de
cela si une pression au niveau aussi
argent de professionnalisation du sport
est-ce que c'est dû à ça le
développement du dopage notamment
mais il ya bien sûr l'argent qui rentre
en massant le sport il ya du deuil à un
dopage du pauvre et un dopage invite
dire du riche idée de pas eu des
pratiques dopantes de plus en plus
sophistiqués on l'a vu avec le système
de lance amstrong où les contrôles ne
s'avérait pas positif parce que bon
c'est un dopage extrêmement sophistiqué
et puis il ya aussi les calendriers
sportifs
attention partie parce que la surchage
dans certains sports fait que
humainement ça entraîne des athlètes à
se doter les utilisations penser la
médiatisation parce que si on fait
beaucoup pop édition c'est parce que les
compétitions on est médiatisé ça
rapporte vous avez entendu ce que disait
françoise lasne à l'instant dans ses
reportages directrice du département des
analyses l agence française de lutte
contre le dopage
elle parlait du rugby sport numéro 1 oui
oui j'ai bien entendu mais moi le moi
n'importe comment je pense que le dopage
existe dans tous les sports faut pas se
raconter des histoires le cycliste à
mark kelly a marqué la lutte contre le
dopage parce que c'était un système très
répandu très organisés dans les équipes
et là aussi c'était un dopage
comprenez facilement bon que dans le
rugby il ait du dopage où je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait pas aussi des
phénomènes dans le rugby
alors les 22 s'est passé pas 22 contrôle
positif faut bien lire cévennes il ya eu
22 ans qu'il n'y a plus de contrôle dans
le rugby que dans le cyclisme morose
non je pense pas c'est pareil à peu près
de toutes les fédérations mais celle-ci
s'est des produits détectés anormaux ses
idées des voix là mais c'est pas des
contrôles positifs les vannes de faisons
attention parce qu'il avait un petit peu
son linge sale est ce que vous croyez
pour cette année offert deux centenaires
vous croyez toujours à ce tour de france
propre moi je suis comme tout le monde
j'ai envie de voir ce tour c'est une
grande fête populaire le tour de france
mais le cyclisme a fait des efforts
notamment les équipes françaises ya
vraiment eu je pense des étapes qui ont
été franchies
voilà le cyclisme mail inquiétant c'est
la fédération internationale c'est
l'union cycliste internationale qui elle
ne bouge pas
ne bougez pas on a toujours les mêmes
dirigeants en place il me fit il ne veut
ni fier en rien alors leur comportement
et leur attitude
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas ce que le
problème j'entendais madame jouanno qui
parlait des fédérations le problème
c'est moins les fédérations françaises
moi j'ai quand même eu un mouvement
sportif qui m'a plutôt accompagner dans
ce combat plutôt qu'il n'a combattu bon
le problème ce sont les un certain
nombre de grandes fédérations
internationales voilà qui qui qui sont
des primes il ya aucune prise
c'est ça le problème de mouvement
sportif national vous avez le public est
impatient olympique vous avez les
grandes fédérations nationales personne
ne les contrôle et comme c'est une série
de cooptation peut pas dire qu'il ya un
débat démocratique d'une grande
intensité à l'intérieur des fédérations
internationales
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas bougé à
l'intérieur du mouvement sportif
international on aura du mal à mener à
bien la lutte antidopage et est apte et
à réguler arriver jusque de l'argent
dans le sport c'est un peu découragé sur
ce sur ce domaine là vous voyez des
paris en ligne
nous paris en ligne les sommes que ça
représente
gardez l'éthique dans le sport avec de
plus en plus de dix ans sur un nul et
notamment pour karabatic vous savez ce
joueur de l'équipe de france alors qu'il
avait été accusé de paris sportifs
illégaux
oui mais écoutez alors là c'est il ya de
la mafia dans les paris sportifs mais
c'est de la mafia au niveau là j'ai
envie de dire qu'est ce qu'ils ont été
bête de faire ça quand même ça c'est de
la bêtise
au japon on va passer au jeudi le sénat
abroge le délit de racolage à 6
c'était une promesse du candidat
hollande les sénateurs en ce jeudi
adopte une proposition de loi
écologistes supprimant le délit de
racolage passif institut en 2003 par une
loi
la dépénalisation vise à rendre moins
fragile la situation des prostituées
flora sauvage supprimer le délit de
racolage passif telle était la volonté
de l'écologiste sert benbassa pour cet
hymne à trith du val de marne ce délit a
conduit à punir les prostituées alors
qu'à ses yeux elle devrait être
considérées comme des victimes
instaurée en 2003 la loi pour la
sécurité intérieure avait pénalisé le
racolage en le punissant d'une peine
maximale de deux mois et de 3750 euros
d'amande au groupe ps on regrette cette
initiative rapide non il faut que cette
loi soit englobé dans une loi plus
importante parce que c'est toi seul à la
fois ne règle rien ne suffit pas voire
même peut-être un signe encourageant
pour les mafieux les proxénètes qui
peuvent se dire voilà en france il n'y a
plus aucun déni sur le racolage
on pourra coller on fera que par
téléphone au parquet par internet il ya
aucun moyen de son côté le racolage
il faudrait pas que ça soit un
encouragement à développer une forme de
prostitution en france que nous voulons
pas pénaliser les clients plutôt que les
prostituées c'est l'objectif du
gouvernement
mais l'auteur de la proposition de loi
examinée cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
est opposé à l'abolition de la
prostitution
moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour la
pénalisation des clients parce que j'ai
vu l'échec en europe et en suède et en
norvège puisqu'on suède les pouvoirs
publics s'enorgueillissent de la
réussite franchement il ya maintenant
des bordels que il les appelle comme ça
des bordels flottant puisque pour
échapper à la réglementation
il le vend avec des prostituées dans des
bateaux qui vogue sur la mer mais le
gouvernement est déterminé un projet de
loi visant à pénaliser les clients de la
prostitution devrait être déposé d'ici à
l'automne 2013
on comprend l'idée pour les prostituées
de mettre moins de pression mais
finalement ça fait le bonheur des mafias
de la prostitution il fallait il fallait
supprimer ceux des livres à pelage
passif parce que c'était les prostituées
qui étaient condamnées et pas les
clients étant même impôt bon mais ceci
dit clients ou souper nazim firme il
faut surtout donner il faut pénaliser le
client
il faut abolir la prostitution et pour
ça il faut aussi donner aux femmes et
aux hommes parce qu'il ya aussi des
hommes du touché par la constitution
il faut leur donner les moyens de se
reconstruire et donne d'entrée dans une
vie professionnelle dont ça va demander
aussi beaucoup moyens il faut mettre
beaucoup de soutien et de moyens pour
permettre à ces hommes et ces femmes de
sortir de la prostitution parce que si
on abolit la prostitution mais nous leur
donne aucune eu aucune issue bon on n'y
arrivera pas donc pénaliser clients et
met en place vraiment un plan pour
l'abolition de la prostitution oui c'est
prostitution au qu'on veuille ou non
quelles que soient les conditions dans
lesquelles elle se fait c'est quand même
la marchandisation du corps dans sa plus
grande violence c'est ok merci beaucoup
mais george buffet d'avoir participé à
notre émission on a senti vous avez des
convictions on a assez peu vu vous
n'étiez pas sûr de voter plus me
permettre
merci beaucoup donc nous on se retrouve